how many hours are in
549 minutes and we can write it as a
decimal or a fraction so essentially
we're going to take 549 minutes and
divide them into groups of 60 why 60
because we know that one hour one hour
is equal to
minutes so it's essentially saying how
many groups of 60 minutes can we divide
549 into
or another way of thinking about that is
well what is 549
divided into groups of 60.
this is how many hours we're going to
have so let's do that let's take 549
and divided it by
and divide it by
60.
so 6 let's see 6 goes into 54 9 times so
60 is going to go to
549 times we're going to have a little
bit left over so we have 9 9 times 60 is
540. we subtract we have nine left over
i'll bring down the let's see we have
nine left over
and now let's see we have a little left
over so we're going to get a decimal so
let's put a decimal place right over
here and let's throw some zeros over
there let's bring down a zero so we
bring down a zero sixty goes into ninety
one time one times sixty is sixty and we
subtract we get thirty let's bring down
another zero
and so we get to 300 60 goes into 300
five times five times sixty five times
six is thirty so five times sixty is
three hundred subtract and we are done
so you divide 549 into groups of 60 you
can divide it into 9.15 groups of 60
minutes a group of 60 minutes is an hour
so this 549 minutes is 9.15
hours i want to make sure that we can
visualize that
visualize that properly
so let's
let's actually construct what 9.15
hours looks like
so
let me draw a little line here
and on the top i'll label hours on the
bottom i'll label minutes so this is 0
hours 0 minutes
and now we have 1 hour which is 60
minutes
now we have 2 hours which is 120 minutes
then you have 3 hours which is 180
minutes
then you have
4 hours which is 240 minutes
5 hours is 300 minutes
6 hours is 360 minutes
seven hours i might be running out of
space is 420 minutes let me copy and
paste this in place where i have more
real estate
so let me
clear that and then let me paste that
someplace where i don't run into my
other math that i did
all right
so then you have
eight hours is 480 minutes
and then you have nine hours notice i'm
just adding 60 minutes every time 9
hours is 540 minutes or another way you
could think about it is well if each
hour is 60 9 times 60 is 540 and we
don't want to go to just 540 we have
another 9 left so then we have to go
we have to go another we have to go
another nine minutes to go to
549 so you have a little nine minutes
left over
so another way of thinking about this
is that 549
is nine hours and then you have nine
minutes left over and nine minutes is
what is what fraction of an hour
well 60 minutes is a whole hour
so nine minutes is 9 60
is 9 60 of an hour so you could write it
this way it's 9 and 9 60 it's hours or
we could write this as an equivalent
fraction 9 over 60 is the same thing if
we divide the numerator and the
denominator by threes the same thing as
three twentieths so we could write this
as nine
and three twentieths
and three over twenty well we could
figure out what that is gonna be let's
see 20 divided by three it's definitely
going to be smaller than one because
three is smaller than 20. so let's throw
some zeros on here
20 doesn't go into three
but it does go into 30 one time 1 times
20 is 20. subtract you get a 10
bring down a 0. 20 goes into 100 5 times
5 times 20 is 100 and we are done so
notice 3 over 20 is the exact same thing
so nine and three twenty is the exact
same thing as nine
and
fifteen hundredths
nine and fifteen hundreds these are all
equivalent answers